foreign
[Music]
is one of the most equivocal unsolved
Riddles In breath of the wild also
referred to by its nickname the bronze
giant due to the color of the Rockets
carved from the statue as it stands
tucked away from view in the Gerudo
Highlands remains an enigma to this day
who built it in whose honor and why here
on a remote Cliffside in such an
unforgiving climate why have they been
wiped from history as the in-game
dialogue and Quest log suggests ever
since the game's launch in 2017 there
have been many attempts to piece
together its origin its meaning and
moreover its identity and there's no
shortage of creative well-researched
ideas and theories about this
captivating mystery unfortunately none
have been able to find the evidence
needed to seal the deal so to speak as
the game nor the book provides
sufficient information to work with and
so just like with the mystery of the
zonai we'll likely have to wait for the
sequel to hopefully she had more light
on it and give us the answers We crave
but before that moment arrives I want to
revisit this mystery one last time to
see if I can offer A New Perspective on
this ancient riddle now that we have
more information about the sequel and to
help me drive this idea into your eyes
and ears I have invited my good friend
Conrad from the Commonwealth realm one
of the OG breath of the wild theorists
on the platform ladies and gentlemen we
present to you what I believe to be the
true face of the eighth heroine
Patricia de San seal
all right I'm kidding it's actually this
one
[Music]
let's start with a brief recap of the
mystery behind the statue or should I
say statues yes as you probably surmise
from the eight in the name is not the
only statue out the other seven are
located in the eastern part of the
scorching desert and as opposed to The
elusive bronze giant these statues are
well known and even revered by the
Garuda themselves they're believed to
represent seven important historical
figures who each possessed a particular
skill and due to the successful
translation of the text featuring on the
Magnificent Stoneworks we know that they
represent none other than the mythical
seven sages a group of individuals who
repeatedly awaken in times of hardship
to help the hero and Princess fend off
the evil tormenting Hyrule many a Time
involving Ganondorf for his alter ego
Ganon it seems the ancient Garuda wanted
to memorialize the sages and thus they
erected these massive Stone monuments in
their honor although the existence of
the seven uncommon knowledge among the
present-taker rudo actual meaning
implication and history seem to have
been all but lost to the women of the
desert they don't know who each
individual statue represents nor do they
even refer to them as sages they're
ecologists think Garuda Town who studies
the monuments named rutana refers to
them as the Divine Protectors of the
Gerudo it even implies that Garuda
believed them to be all female warriors
even though the seven sages have
historically been a mix of many
different races and genders it shows
that while her research is slowly
progressing her deeper understanding is
still right with misinterpretation and
bias viewing them from the perspective
of the gorilla alone and not from high
rules combined history and culture this
is not surprising though of the ancient
and present-day Garuda are very
particular about the Memorial's
historical figures not only are they all
betrayed as female presumably in their
own image but they also left nameless
and are instead inscribed with poetry or
singular adjectives like fidget it's no
wonder why the identity of these figures
are eventually forgotten as the ages
creeped by the existence of the eight
Heron on the other hand seemed to be
completely unknown to the present-day
Garuda where at the very least written
off as nothing more than an urban legend
one description even mentions that the
remote section of the Highlands where
the statue resides is one that the
Garuda did not set foot in because of
the many dangers including the extreme
weather conditions as such none of the
Garuda who are alive today have ever
laid eyes upon the eighth heroine let
alone known who or what it is supposed
to personify when it comes to the
ancient Garuda however it is a different
story it's all but certain that they
were well aware of and ate heroine not
only are they the most likely candidate
for its construction seeing as the
architecture is close to identical to
the other seven but the Yeager clown
Hideout which is confirmed to be an
ancient crude archaeological site
features 8 similar looking statues
facing each other in a circle
likewise we can see that the seven
massive monuments tucked away inside the
desert have an empty space that would
have fit an eighth statue perfectly one
final detail about the eighth heroine is
that the sword they are supposed to
clench onto as seen on the other seven
is missing from the statue itself and
can instead be found Atop The Summit of
the Highlands not far away for what
reason no one knows for sure
so these are some of the basic facts
about the statues there is a bit more to
it but we'll cover those as we go along
given how few people seem to be aware of
the existence of the eighth heroine it's
hard to pinpoint its exact placement in
hyrule's history or which parts of the
rumors about it are true or false
especially when the culture that
supposedly built it seems completely
oblivious to it and thus cannot provide
us any insight I joked before about
Patricia but she's actually one of only
two beings in the world who mentioned
the eighth heroine by name through
dialogue the other being bosai you know
the creepy guy who tries to get into
Link's pants and gives you the quest to
seek out the statue not even the town
archaeologist who I remind you actively
studies the history of the seven
heroines every day ever even mentions
the rumors about an eighth statue in the
case of bosai I can understand why you
would know about it since he is a Hylian
he says he's been intrigued by the
stories of an eighth heroine ever since
he was a child so apparently it is a
legend that some hylians dare speak of
but how in the heck does the pet seal
belonging to the leader of the Gerudo
know about it and why has no one ever
caught on to the fact even the woman who
interprets her words of wisdom doesn't
even Flinch when mentioning the eighth
heroine look at her she's completely
unfazed I mean come on lady it's a
central part of your religion this would
be like if a Christian found out there
were secretly 11 Commandments but I
don't know Moses lost one on the way
down from the mountain anyway there's
two important details which have given
shape to many similar theories and
verdicts about the nature and identity
of the eighth heroine first is to claim
that as stated before the statue itself
as well as the person it embodies have
been wiped clean from history and second
is a quest lock that says that despite
being lost in memory she is still
worshiped to this day by her faithful in
the Gerudo highlands now the only
faction we know that lives in the
highlands are of course the yiga who
have been fiercely loyal to Ganon ever
since they seceded from the Chica 10 000
years ago the fact that the eighth
heroine has been wiped from history yet
is still worshiped by what is
essentially a Ganon cult has led many to
believe that this individual could have
been on the wrong side of history and
possibly involved in some some nefarious
act perhaps a sage gone Rogue who
betrayed the other seven or as some
suggest it may even be a memorial to
Ganon himself why else with the yiga of
all people pay homage to this forgotten
Idol there's a piece of NPC dialogue
that reiterates the same basic concept
as the quest log except here instead of
calling them her faithful it instead
refers to them as the people who hang
around the Gerudo Highlands which
further reinforces that this would
indeed have to be the yiga as day and
day alone fit the description the game
generally doesn't refer to things like
Monsters or Wildlife as people there is
however one problem one that has plagued
the Zelda series for decades and
continues to do so here localization
differences the original Japanese text
never actually refers to these mystery
worshipers as her faithful nor as the
people who hang around the grudo
highlands it simply says her followers
instead on the surface this may seem
like a very minor difference but for a
theory this can have massive
repercussions the English text Advocates
that these devotees are human beings
which inadvertently eliminates any
alternatives because like I said as far
as people go there are none who hang
around these parts in the present day no
one but the eager well in link but he
doesn't count meanwhile the Japanese
text keeps it ambiguous after all
followers can apply to anyone really
anyone who's sentient anyway I believe
that this tiny seemingly harmless
translation difference may just be
responsible for limiting our perspective
on the mystery of the eighth heroine
since what if this isn't referring to
the yiga at all but instead someone else
the yiga have never been a very logical
choice to me despite the English texts
insisting that they are they don't seem
to concern themselves at all with the
reverence of ancient monuments
especially those belonging to other
cultures in fact they appear to be
completely indifferent even downright
disrespectful towards them for example
the statues located in their Hideout
which features the eighth one all have
their face dishonorably covered in
drapes which displays their Insignia no
doubt intended as a giant middle finger
to the Gerudo who they are still at war
with they do the same thing to chica
Idols too by the way I see no evidence
that they held these monuments in any
sort of high regard so why would they
venture out into the frigid coal to
worship this one sure their Hideout is
in the highlands but it's still quite
the expedition to get to the eighth
heroine another aspect that potentially
works against the yiga is the extreme
secrecy behind the statue as well as the
timeline of events what's quite
distinctive about the Statue is that
unlike the side of the seven heroines it
doesn't feature a shika Shrine the
ancient chica constructed their shrines
all over Hyrule in the most obscure
secretive older sites imaginable find an
ancient ruin chances are there's going
to be a shrine nearby even instructors
that stem from the time of Skyward Sword
which is an insanely long time ago so
why not here could it be that even the
shika from 10 000 years ago were
oblivious to the ace statue if so how
would the yiga know where it is let
alone who the statue represents the clan
didn't form until after the Calamity of
ten thousand years ago when the king of
Hyrule started persecuting the shika in
their technology if we stick by the
Japanese text and assume that these
so-called followers are not necessarily
human beings more options suddenly
become available and one in particular
stands out as a prime candidate for me
especially in context with the sequel an
intelligent being who's not only present
in the highlands but one that actually
visits the area in and around the eighth
heroine frequently despite originating
from the fahren region the lightning
Spirit farage has two secondary flight
paths one at Lake hylia and the other
sees it snaking around the Gerudo
Highlands drifting in from the southern
part of the mountain range right past
the Forgotten sword makes its way close
to the top of the statue then travels in
between the statue and the sword after
which it curves back around the summit
for subsequent visits until finally
taking off into the heavens at some
point but it gets even better because
now take a look at the flight path of
dinroll the fire dragon from the Elden
region after spawning and passing along
the back of the volcano it heads
Southwest then makes a straight shot
through the canyon towards the Cliffside
where the statue is located until it too
decides to call it a day and head for
the clouds I'd say it almost looks like
it's on a pilgrimage of sorts the only
dragon who doesn't exert a similar
behavior is Nedra and while that does
somewhat weaken the argument for a
statue worshiping ceremony by the
dragons we do have to keep in mind that
Nedra has been incapacitated by Ganon
for what we can presume to be a
considerable amount of time before link
wakes up from his stasis and depending
on the order in which you explore Hyrule
it remains trapped on the mountain until
link finally cures its Affliction a
valid enough excuse to skip daily
service for a while I suppose with that
said what could the ancient dragon
spirits who have been around since time
immemorial possibly wand with a statue
like this well that all depends on what
the secret identity behind this Monument
is if it is someone they knew well or as
the in-game text suggests if followed it
would make perfect sense for the dragon
spirits to pay their respects to them
especially if that individual died or
sacrificed themselves for a greater
purpose in the distant past as mighty
images stick as the dragon Smith appear
they are not above Gods sages
contemporary Spirit guardians or other
types of deities in Skyward Sword for
example they control parts of their
respective provinces but did so in the
service of goddess hylia who appointed
them to protect the surface in her
absence and here's where another major
difference in the localization comes
into play the nickname of the eight
heroine we have been reiterating
throughout the video is actually not
accurate to the original Japanese name
there it is the carpet giant goddess you
can see the impact of omitting a single
word as it makes a world of difference
as opposed to just another Sage this
statue is hinted to be a tribute to a
goddess of source which is not nearly on
the same level as a sage this brings us
to the latest footage for tears of the
Kingdom the figure depicted on a mural
definitely fits the characteristics of a
deity they appear to reside high in the
heavens suspended on a floating platform
with rays of light shining down upon
them more importantly the seven all
black artifacts that surround them could
reinforce a connection between this
entity and seven other beings the other
mentioned sages perhaps just like we see
with the statues eight in total with one
different from the rest speaking of
differences there's one more feature
about the eighth statue we haven't
mentioned so far it's not just that the
material is different and the sword is
missing but it also happens to be a
mirrored version of the other seven
monuments and lo and behold what do we
see on the mural two depictions of the
same symbol but mirroring each other one
on the side of what is presumably to be
an incarnation of Zelda and which
matches the symbol on the orbs and the
mirror opposite on the side of this
deity figure a coincidence it definitely
could be but if it is it is a very
interesting coincidence if this theory
is correct and the dragons are indeed
the ones worshiping the eight heroine
statue instead of the yika naturally
obvious candidate to shoot for will be
goddess highly given the history between
her and the dragon spirits and it very
well could be but we certainly shouldn't
rule out all the possibilities as well
there's a good chance that this is a
brand new deity whom we have never seen
or met before
let's wrap up the video with a final
piece of conjecture one that my guest
speaker may not resonate with so I want
to make it clear that these are my
thoughts and mine alone whoever or
whatever this creature on the mural ends
up being chances are we probably won't
get any decisive answers until we
actually you know play Tears of the
Kingdom in that sense the mystery behind
the eighth heroine remains for now
however I do have a strong conviction
that this character and the 8th heroine
are likely one and the same there's just
too many overlapping themes and
coincidences for me to ignore in fact I
would take it a step further and say
that the spectral being who has
Ganondorf pinned down and sealed deep
underground may also be connected to it
it definitely has a spiritual out of
this world kind of look and feel to it
so maybe the green Hand That Remains is
what's left of this ancient deity the
figure on the mural is shown to be
pretty huge in comparison to a regular
human or at least compared to Zelda if
this is indeed her now look at the size
comparison between Link's hand and the
one belonging to this entity it's like
twice the size whatever this creature
used to be it too must have been and
pretty big when link absorbs the green
energy The Entity seems to pass its
Essence down to the hero which explains
why he can suddenly conjure up these
almost god-like powers like the ability
to control time or become incorporeal
and move through solid matter in context
with today's subject it would also
clarify why this individual has been
completely forgotten over the course of
history perhaps long ago they sacrificed
their very existence to keep ganondorf's
physical body from being set loose upon
Hyrule once again they were then
memorialized in stone by the Ancients
but as the years crept by the memory of
their sacrifice and even their very
identity was slowly lost a time which is
a common occurrence in the land of
Hyrule it only took ten thousand years
for the Calamity to completely Fade Into
myth which mind you was a huge battle
involving giant robots and whatever
transpired back when Ganondorf was still
human clearly took place much much
longer ago
and that wraps up today's video if you
liked it please be sure to check out
Conrad's video as well over on his
channel the Commonwealth realm and if
you didn't be sure to check out Conrad's
video over on his channel regardless
because it may be way better than mine a
special Thanks goes to larulia historian
for providing me with the Japanese texts
and of course to my mods Discord
community patreons and channel members I
will see you all in the next video this
is Don signing off and have a good one
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign